[Music]
hey y'all another episode of you welcome
here with me Marcelo Arguello we have
some great guests today the very
hilarious Steph tall of who has a great
vinyl album ready for pre-order I'm not
well and she isn't she's hilarious also
the Comedy Central digital series called
Stefan Deb check that out and we have
Nicole Byer who is on tour right now
check out all of her dates on Nicole
Byer was taken calm ladies thank you for
being here hey for having us how are you
doing with know nothing I was like I'm
not gonna sing my reply but it sounded
good when you did it did it I don't know
if you should being mean I don't think I
am I can't tell anymore
I can't tell you're meaner I can't no I
can't
yeah I can't tell or mean been like that
your whole life for yeah for a very long
time when you were like yes people were
very I was a very scary muppet as a kid
I think it started in like in middle
school a great eight I don't have I
don't even smoke so I don't know what
the hell it's very strange
I don't know funny if you're a five year
old smell hey hey Dad Christmas mmm come
again this year and just do you ever
manipulate your voice if you're going
into an audition no no no I probably I
really should I'm like you every single
addition I go to they're like you gonna
tone it down I don't know what you're
doing this is that so not the part I
probably should I probably book more if
I talk to my girl I'm a little baby I
said even fun
it still has a raspy wait I'll try to
try to try to go up out here I have to
tell men when I sound like before I go
into their dates because I meet them
they like I'm like hey I'm so sorry
that's actually what I sound like
are you talking about that on stage they
probably shed its s you okay wait you to
specifically you talk about dating a lot
I'm your acts online oh I don't date at
all so I never talk about dating because
I don't do it what why are you putting
yourself through this
mm-hmm because
worth it no not anymore I don't think it
is I don't I hate it will you tell this
night of what happened to us okay so
last night this is so gross
fool y'all this guy's looking a meth
head doesn't matter it was lightly
making it with my neck and then he got a
little carried away and then he bit but
I have a mole on my neck and I don't
know how he didn't see it or if he's
blind but he bit it and it bled I hate
my life I don't want to date me Maura
that's it I deleted tinder I believe it
bum bum over how gross is that are you
blind
it looks like a [ __ ] junior minute
are you [ __ ] it's the I hate it I'm
recovering now feeling self-conscious
about if I'm like I just can't believe
what and he didn't even notice that's
the worst part I was like and it was a
bleeding
oh and I'm like now I Drive cancer like
I go sick he's sick you got a mole
fetish he's into it you should wear the
other molds on you guys show me other
yeah anyone ever bit your mom no one's
ever bit my mole what happens is that
children look two-year-olds just go what
do you say and they touch it and I just
stare at them because it's funny
watching them realize that it's
three-dimensional what he did except he
went for it
it's like to touch my face - you have a
cute face I'm a cartoon face I do have
like a cartoon face yeah you do it's
great it's hard is it yeah because I'm
kind of like a cartoon person I've like
a big personalities why the kids like
the show nailed a life that's why they
love it because I'm like a living
cartoon yeah my Lisa's love you it's
weird yeah you've heard my jokes right
now I don't want my niece's to know
about you it's so weird but whenever I
have an audition I have to remember to
like not be a cartoon cuz people in the
world are real yeah
and that's so hard I just want to be
maybe like but that's how I am in real
life that's why your standup works yes
is white goofy
recently the founder of a specific type
of conversion therapy came out as a
homosexual what a shocker right isn't
that crazy yeah he caused a lot of drama
but that I'm not on board with it was
bad but also maybe the conversion
therapy it worked
in the opposite way mm-hmm aha Nicola
around him that he was trying to turn
that the gays were like give me that
Nick and then he turned to them I feel
like anybody would go to the extent to
even start a conversion therapy anybody
who is that upset with gay people is gay
yours I mean there's anybody who's gonna
get that crazy oh that's what that
stereotype of like people who hate gay
people are secretly gay I mean that
stereotype is awful but it exists
because of people like that well if
you're gonna go out of your way to try
to convert other people like let them
live what are you doing yeah it'll get a
grip get a life I don't understand the
get your own [ __ ] life but now he's
like was he saying now he's ago upset
like no you're yeah he's really upset
he's like I ruin people's lives I was
like yeah bro yeah yeah do you like dick
yeah yeah dicks I mean we all have dick
but we don't need to ruin each other
around me Nicole more than most I think
oh my god convert that I want to go do
that I think I need to now you know
what's funny about this event it Steph
walked in she's like I don't want I
don't want to talk about this but and
then she tells me immediately I'm like
okay I didn't realize she was telling
everybody right now she was like yes
think about it salsa the mind of a comic
works for something terrible happens and
you try to be like I gotta bury this
[ __ ] or it ends up it means I'm your big
closer watch my first special and then
it's gonna be a zoom in of the camera
going to the argument put two googly
eyes on her and then I'm gonna make the
mole say the last bit see that's funny
that's funny
has anyone ever tried to talk you out of
doing something and then you realize
like oh they're like super into this
like the DARE program they're telling
you not to do drugs and then you find
out like your dad smoked sweet and
that's what he was always like not
trying to hang out there madera campaign
probably is bad yeah they should show
kids people on drugs and be like look at
that lady having the time of her life
right she gave up everything for this
right do you want to do the same that's
what I would do hey I mean that's it I
had a conversation with my niece because
like she's following elite accounts and
I think everyone in the family is like
they don't know how to navigate the
conversation i sat her down
and I was like you know the human brain
stops growing at 25 which is she's a
smart kid so I was like this is gonna
capture her attention and she was like
it does I guess it crazy starts it just
keeps developing I'm here twenty five
years old and you think it's a one
you're okay like we're having this
conversation about the brain and I was
like and that's why I'm glad I waited to
do drugs until I was in my twenties
because my brain was developed and she
was like a wood and it was like a really
smart way to like plant that in her head
weed is okay yes I do agree that weed is
okay but the problem is like it's once
you if you're a kid mm-hmm and you start
doing weed yes then doing the offers of
other drugs I mean if you do weed I do
either and the offers for other drugs
start coming in cuz that's the thing I
hate that phrase weed is a gateway drug
but like if you're a kid yeah it can be
a gateway drug if they just old kids
pills are fun don't go look at you know
homegirl down there I think kids with
not do them I mean no they would do them
because they're fun yeah but if you're
like she has no shoes on and her pussy's
out you wanna be
like her some of them are like yeah why
not that's for the Frank Frank and then
your [ __ ] drops out exactly that would
be that would be something that was
scare me and then the other conversation
of like abstinence only programs raising
a [ __ ] dog so doc you've kids condom
yes I agree give girls birth control
yeah give it they're gonna be [ __ ] in
second yeah actually no [ __ ] you suck
who doesn't love a little pocket in
second that's also the the recently oh
your wife a commercial founders just
kind of scared I don't know you notice
my object work but I also squeeze tiny
balls oh wow with one hand to you don't
need to hit just use the tips of your
nails that's great Justin Bieber posted
on Instagram essentially a meltdown of
why being a child star sucks and why
being famous sucks and I want to ask
both of you ladies are famous people
crazy think about it I mean I think you
I think yeah I think so I think if you
were like I mean you get recognized a
lot
yeah already I feel like if that
happened to you daily and you were just
constantly like getting stalked by like
TV you'd go [ __ ] yes right privacy
like Brad Pitt can't go to tender greens
you know he you can't go anywhere when
you're these people I will say I am
always humbled everywhere I go so I
don't think I'll ever get crazy what do
you mean by that
when I did late night on Late Night with
Seth Meyers as I was walking in there
was paparazzi I'd never had paparazzo it
was very exciting it was for Vanessa
Hudgens who was on before me and I was
walking and I was coming on I was like
posing and then I was like I'm gonna end
up on Getty and this little girl goes
mama who is she and then the mom went
that's a person and like oh man this
woman and it was fully in earshot it
really so truly things like that
happened
all the time you're actually on a show
where people like I got stopped in
Toronto bragging and this guy lives off
the tracks he's like oh my god I went
anyway you've seen me on TV music no you
used to serve me at doves baby swings
and I'm like I haven't worked that
restaurant in 10 years I'm like you
remember me pick your bone bucket like I
remember that I love them but also
Justin Bieber said he was doing hard
drugs I need to know what hard drugs he
was doing what hard drugs do you think
he was doing hello to suburban white boy
think are hard drugs at 19 years old I
mean he's not working he's doing heroin
to me heroin and meth are hard drugs so
do you think he was doing heroin maybe
you heard it here first Nicole Byer uses
Justin Bieber of heroin addiction that
to me was I heard this drug you've ever
done I've done mushrooms I think that's
the hardest thing I've ever done well I
get diarrhea when I have mushrooms so
that's why all the I [ __ ] my bed once
there's a lot yeah not good knock I
don't know why I'm bringing this up
bleeding mole [ __ ] my bed yeah I'm
single boys album I'm not well it's very
obvious I'm very sick I physically am
sick um I had Sade up the night before
cuz I was so sick for the mushrooms I
had no sleep so I'd like to finally lie
down for like 20 minutes and I woke up
I'm like there's more of that you're
gonna take a new mattress if anybody
wants to come over your gut very nice so
there Oh better for your second special
wait I said that stuff is judging this
man for nibbling normal I didn't wash it
it was okay it was bad and accidents
happen it should appreciate I think he
accepted your body for what it was
trouble you ever [ __ ] in your bed no oh
maybe when I was a child
have you of course I'm an adult having
fun oh I am the most uptight person I do
not have fun I'm super uptight oh yeah
okay yeah so you don't have fun when you
share I don't shoot myself and now we're
at the Q&A portion of you welcome if you
have any questions about life love
stress setbacks submit them to you
welcome questions at gmail.com yes I
wasn't atmos for your reference right
ladies you ready to answer these
questions yes and thank you for everyone
to Jim submitting so hungry how do you
stay positive during and after a bad
breakup I'm really struggling with this
and could use some advice from some bad
[ __ ] mm-hmm ladies who date positive
well I have been publicly shaming them
and getting oh that's funny before I had
to take down tweet but um what was the
tweet I tweeted a photo of a guy that
goes me off bumble and then people kind
of start trolling me and I had to take
it down they saying to you that this is
I'm not allowed to do this and I'm the
problem with women
a woman said I'm the problem with women
and she was Pro goes classic woman yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
you wouldn't be doing if they were in a
[ __ ] yes exactly yeah yeah yeah
that's why I liked that post that you
made because it was like I mean you were
being thorough with what happened wait
what happened what'd he do he was just
this guy who was like literally we had
this huge talk I was like look I hate
ghosts and when a few dates either grab
my hand he went I would never
they went on a few days other day thing
yeah y-yeah literally the last time it
was can't wait to see you again
and I have not heard will never again
yeah so it's like I'm gonna out these
[ __ ] up you for being [ __ ] biological
liar a new term called zombie egg that's
when someone ghosts you but then a
couple months later is like hey what's
up like nothing happened tortured yeah
Wow that's not a new way that feels like
something that has I feel like that
brings you joy well I that's a kind of
good advice I feel like you should be
negative after a bad breakup if it's a
bad breakup it's okay to not be positive
sure yeah feel your feelings you're
entitled to that but like don't get
wrapped up over somebody else you can't
control that person you can control your
feelings so after you're sad and in your
feelings for a little bit you gotta move
on you do something that like takes your
mind off [ __ ] and things you joy yes I
agree
alright whatever that may be for you
watch nailed it on Netflix yes please
every stream we're gonna cut that okay
next question what do you think of
friend breakups do friendships require a
specific conversation to end it or is
ghosting acceptable no ghosting is never
acceptable forefront stopping it doesn't
matter what the damn situation stop
being a [ __ ] coward I think you
should yes especially for long yeah yes
that's a full conversation yeah that's a
big time sit-down conversation and we're
adults at this point you can say exactly
what it is absolutely breakups are very
honest about it I think it's good to
give it a like a little space so that
you don't say anything while he does yes
back for because I think that's the the
issue when people want to do it right
away and you do need to go okay wait let
me take a moment yeah whether it's a day
or a week or whatever you're not for a
bit yeah
and then you yes so don't I pour a bit
to think about it so you don't say
anything crazy to your friend sure yeah
especially your friends because you know
like if that guy said something to you
it would have upset you but you would
have moved on easier because he would
have yes said it to you yeah very simple
but like the the ghosting I
I do agree it's pretty [ __ ] up and
it's also like what children do because
they don't know how to handle their [ __ ]
yes but it puts you in a headspace that
you're like whoa what was it what did I
do when I say so but how it look like
and then you get like so crazy and like
mean to yourself over someone just being
back fall for no reason
yes have you ever ghosted a friend now
I've never ghosted a friend anytime I've
moved on from a best friend I've had a
conversation with I'm gonna be like
you're the issues that have arose
let's try to work on that and then when
it doesn't work it's like I don't think
I can hang out with you very you know
what I find interesting is that cuz
women are such good friends and men are
such bad friends like and I think it's
because they don't hold each other
accountable and they way that talk well
that's what you think they don't hold
each other accountable and they don't
say hey maybe you should like men do it
when it's like the last resort like okay
he's not he's doing heroin mhm
and he keeps cheating on the girl no we
think is a good girlfriend so like maybe
we should be like hey bro chill out and
that's all they say you know they don't
really get that into it but that's what
I've noticed a pattern of like men
because men stay friends for [ __ ] and
sometimes don't even like that pretty
old weird bad [ __ ] to each other or like
yeah yeah it's not that's very strange I
think we just need to teach little boys
that it's okay to talk about your
feelings and that's not emasculating
it's how humans work yes I agree and
then watch nailed it on that I'm dealing
with this in terms of finding my voice
Who I am on stage but I'm also wondering
generally how do you figure out how
other people see you who I think I am
and who other people think I am seem to
be pretty different and I don't know how
to rectify that oh damn I want more
information me too but I also feel like
you shouldn't worry about how other
people see you yeah I think this is it
great I think that's why I picked this
question because you two are wildly
yourself so proudly yourselves yeah and
I think that answering this question and
it's good for both of you like how did
you come to terms with like the
personality and like who you are
physically to the point where you just
you have to stop caring about what other
people like you know the nose comment
it's like you're like this aminos yeah
it took you about it to get there right
I'd say well they I got bullied really
badly in high school yeah I think after
that I kind of wasn't the [ __ ] and then
I looked and now all those losers are
balding and they have horrible ugly fat
wife's so my son great but my life but I
have looked at their Facebook's
anyways no I I it took me a while but I
like it really was as soon as I stopped
caring about myself a lot of you have
thought of myself
I'll people thought I just it was way
easier to be happy and like Yuri doesn't
matter you don't care like it really
doesn't matter yeah and what something
else I feel like you can also control
the way people perceive you like if you
can have a control of how you're
perceived that's like super helpful and
the long run especially because it
sounds like this person is a performer
yeah I assume that the early stages
because they're asking this question
yeah I am just so confused how you can
think people have a different perception
upon looking at you do you know I mean
yeah like I know people see a fat black
woman right with tiny titties and a fat
ass who seems like fun
yeah and I think that's who I am yeah
that's accurate so I'm so confused as to
what they would physically yes physical
well then if it's stuff inside of you
tell them that's your comedy right I'm
saying yes that's so that's good because
it's true because when you're like I
said when you're on stage you're having
control of how people get to know you
and your personality yeah and that's
when you kind of navigate what the
physical perception versus the the
whatever your personality type is or
what you want people to believe yes or
in a place right now though I feel like
as if she just stand up like I think
that's why people love you because you
are yourself and you are wheel I think
we're at a place now where people are
connecting more when someone's genuine
and actually themselves on stage
yeah like if I was a quiet woman I would
probably start my sets with I know you
think I'm going to scream but I've never
screamed before I don't know some way
yeah so I think you just maybe if you
think people think one thing about you
you need to address that maybe you think
this about me but this is what's
actually true
yeah you got a authentically be yourself
like I can't talk about [ __ ] I don't
know about right what's your point about
yeah yeah I mean controlling the
narrative of who you are as yeah Gordon
especially as a stand-up assuming yeah I
don't know yeah you can see right
through you too you know
yeah we're like from an honest place and
maybe that's where she's coming from
maybe she's coming from a place of like
she has had this perception of herself
that she thought she was navigating well
and now she's on stage and she has to be
a little more honest and maybe she's
having a hard time with that also it's
hard even when you're honest so like
when I started trying to do fat jokes
people kept me like oh no right right I
thought that was of negative word a
negative word I was sad about it me
getting on stage talking about it would
make me psychotic yeah that would be an
insane person no I'm trying to make you
laugh so I think maybe if she's getting
or they're getting those types of
reactions or who were like no you have
to figure out a way to actually speak to
what they see do you know I'm saying yes
like when I was I started telling fat
jokes I would be like you don't have to
feel bad for me and giving them reasons
why not to and then going into the jokes
which is an extra step that I was like
why do I need this right but I think
that might be in control like I said it
could be because you know that their
their perception is hindered by whatever
kind of [ __ ] that they're carrying
with them because they've also been told
oh being a fat black woman it's it's own
hurdle so let me not laugh at the jokes
that she's making but you're taking
control of it and you're normalizing it
to become that's also a radical concept
for a stand-up comic you know I mean
before that it was like Monique and that
was it yes and and we're have someone
who's young and not you know in the same
Avenue as Monique so they're it's it's
it is radical for you to be doing that
and I think it's important for you to be
doing that but it's also like kind of
make it so that the next generation can
do whatever the [ __ ] they wanna do and
make it easier thank you ladies so much
this was such a fun episode thank you
can I come back absolutely never I had
so much fun let me come back hi Nicole
you can watch me I nailed it or here
when I come back I love this show my
cell is my best friend
what she don't know yeah honestly I
don't know
and on that note welcome [ __ ]
[Music]
you